do
[Music]
all right
we are going to get started we have a
few seats left here you are welcome to
sit from the bar as well
oh boy welcome everybody back to the
interval it has been a very very long
time please give yourself a round of
applause for actually showing up
um this is our first
kind of real live talk uh back here at
the interval in in a few years and so
thank you and and this has also been a
talk that i've been talking with creon
about doing for a very very long time
um and unfortunately the problem of
space debris has not gotten better
since we started talking about this
but uh
it's one of the issues like asteroid
impacts like climate change
that um
that we all face as as a civilization
and i think it's it's one of those
things that
potentially we don't give the right do
um
as we as we think on legalizational
scale
so i'm going to start with a
dramatized version of space debris
uh from the movie gravity
and then
and then after that creon is going to
begin his talk here we go
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
i hate space
[Music]
um
that was an exaggeration
that was the hollywood version of uh
space collisions and um
interesting movie gravity
the entire movie takes place
in the absence of gravity until the very
last few seconds
where she makes it safely back to earth
uh anyway
um that was supposed to be the
destruction of the international space
station due to an earlier collision that
happens a few orbits previously
the wrench thing is the nod to uh
various objects that have been
accidentally
released in space we'll be talking more
about that um
this is more
reality this is uh okay i worked at nasa
for decades and
for the last few years
i spent a lot of time on the space
debris problem i'll talk about why
shortly
this is uh
my hand and this is a experiment that
was run at the
nasa johnson space flight center space
debris divisions hyper velocity impact
facility and
what we see here is an aluminum plate
that has been impacted at orbital
velocities
by a
small steel bb
that is not the bb that impacted the
plate and the plate was cut in half but
this is what can happen
uh at those velocities with collisions
with even small objects and
[Music]
this is a slightly
larger experiment this is a satellite
mock-up
actually if you know what that thing on
the left is it was highly classified for
a long time but that's another story um
but uh
this is a typical you know
space
small space vehicle maybe a meter in
length
maybe a little longer and this
hypervelocity impact
with a one centimeter marble-sized
aluminum sphere moving at
the relative velocity that your average
space collision with orbit might happen
and on the
result
fragments that they reassembled
after the
collision with the one
marble-sized object so
small small objects can make a big
mess and
talk about
probabilities and stuff later i got
drawn into this because i was asked
in
the year again 2009 i think it was 2009
there was a big
renewed interest in
the space debris and space collision
avoidance problem space traffic
management problem
all sort of names of
related problems when the
uh
when an
uh
iridium satellite which is a
communication satellite which there are
many in orbit collided with a
defunct
russian
cosmos satellite i forget what its
purpose was but uh we don't really know
what happened in fact the collision
wasn't even predicted interesting you
know even with all the trapping of space
objects that have been done in 2009 they
collided and a big debris cloud was
tracked there's a whole
radar network an optical network of
things around the earth tracking space
objects we don't have time to get into
great detail on that but as near as we
can tell this is probably what happened
in the collision
was the um
iridium just nicked this like boom that
was sticking out of the cosmos cosmos is
the left-hand one and then this cloud of
particles came about this was a
simulation done by lawrence livermore
labs trying to sort of
retrodict what actually happened there
and this was thousands of fragments
thousands of trackable sized fragments
and of course every one of these
fragments can potentially collide with
something else and make more fragments
now
this fortunately has been
relatively rare
this got me into this this
topic and it's related to celestial
mechanics and all kinds of other space
things and so uh i read a ton about it
and orbit determination is part of it
tracking
statistics and then eventually ended up
with some of my colleagues at nasa some
of who later went on to found planet
labs where i currently work
published a bunch of papers on this
topic
this is just to say that i i know
something about it not one of the
world's experts on this but but
uh
getting close
uh so
so um
you know i worked on it for a couple
years but not my whole career uh so the
traveling gravity movie was was showing
a dramatization of something happening
at the international space station and
this is a big concern like we really
don't want anything even remotely like
that we don't even want anything to
happen to the international space
station we don't even want a little tiny
hole in it although
we'll talk more about that in a minute
it's truly an international project in
fact one might argue that you know one
of the reasons the us and russia don't
go to war is because
there's u.s and russian astronauts up on
the space station at all times and it's
sort of a soft power kind of detent
diplomacy
uh
stabilization for us politically
technologically it's an astonishing
thing it's it's it's probably the most
expensive
apparatus ever constructed
cern
the large hadron collider might might
also be up there but um
it's enormous uh you can't hardly even i
don't think you can see a human at this
scale it's about one football field in
length
uh all the the solar arrays are being
impressed but the whole rest of it is
pretty much pressurized
uh it's got japanese modules european
modules
us modules russian modules
they're all interconnected they're all
interoperated it's it's been
up there for 24 years
it took a few years to to get it fully
built and it's had at least seven people
on it pretty much continuously for 24
years rotating cruise international
and uh over 250
astronauts from 19 different countries
have um
been on board the iss
let's see i think this next chart it
kind of this also shows like you can
have there typically there are space
vehicles from many different countries
and many different
companies docked at the international
space station and so it's a hive of
activity experiments and
a lot of the time is spent just
maintaining it
um but for anyone who thinks you know
living on mars is within our reach
let's just say living in in low earth
orbit is
very expensive and
problematic even on its own
um
so
there have been some debris strikes on
the international space station that we
know
about uh here's
the canadians have big contributions to
robotics on the space station and so uh
unfortunately one of their robots has
been
damaged by a debris strike again this
was probably only like
maybe a few millimeters in size the
object that made that hole
we don't know
uh
there's this beautiful thing on the
international space station called the
coppola which is this sort of
picture
window dome thing where you can it has
no real purpose other than people
looking through it and taking pictures
to it and taking pictures of it and they
lie there and they look down at the
earth
in this panoramic view
and uh
and
it's very beautiful thing it's great
that they made it
but what other people don't use on the
outside of it there are these shields
that can be folded up
particularly when they know that there's
a piece a lot of times they will know
that there's a piece of debris that's on
the way
nicely to collide with the space station
but maybe to pass within a few
kilometers of it
potentially and so
actually every time that they know that
there's a substantial size piece of
debris and by substantial i mean
anything we can track and by anything we
can track in low earth orbit i mean
anything that's about five centimeters
in size or bigger
so there's a lot of stuff that's smaller
than that which we'll talk about but
when they know that there's something
five centimeters in size or bigger that
is um
has a conjunction probability of more
than i don't know one in ten thousand
with the space station they have to go
they have to close they don't have to go
out they close these shields and they
actually get ready in the various
human capable vehicles that are on the
space station to evacuate
if a catastrophe happens
uh
here's some tiny thing that hit one of
the windows of the coppola didn't break
it but you know
all kinds of things
up there uh this is a
solar array uh from the hubble space
telescope
that was um
uh
retrieved after nine years in orbit and
brought back to earth
this is definitely debris strikes
i don't know the size of these solar
cells we're looking they're probably at
least like
five by ten centimeters each of those
things may be bigger
uh this is a
selfie taken by the sentinel one
spacecraft the european space agency
radar
uh synthetic aperture radar mission and
this
on the left is before and on the right
is after
um
a debris strike
um
that
is above
that to show the red arrow it's pointing
to is about 40 centimeters in diameter
so
this drawing on the chalkboard
also shown here
is from the original uh paper in 1978
by don kessler and his associates he was
the man who essentially invented
this field or started thinking about the
problem of space debris and he started
thinking about it in the 70s and there
had been no known space collisions at
that time
and uh
he was just thinking you know what if we
keep launching stuff into space and you
know occasionally stuff blows up and
occasionally pieces come off and
there's going to be a probability that
things could collide over time and
create more pieces and what might the
cumulative number of collisions look
like given different scenarios and
simple mods and these are relatively
simple models you've got newtonian
dynamics of objects in orbit that's been
understood for a very long time and then
you've got collision probabilities and
you can make pretty good guesses about
that
and uh he made this graph showing
predicted cumulative numbers of
collisions based on different
assumptions about how many or how many
objects were launched each year
now i should point out that it's now the
2020s and we're launching
many thousands of objects per year not
just
a thousand or so like it's shown here
um so
i went and i
the nasa
johnson center has a whole debris office
with like dozens of people in it who
study this professionally for their
whole career and they publish a
newsletter i think quarterly and one of
the things the newsletter has in
addition to research is um
it has
discussions about various events
that happen in orbit and some are called
collisions and that's where they're
pretty sure based on tracking that
something collided and other types of
events are called fragmentations
and fragmentations
or particularly unknown fragmentations
fragmentations can happen for many
reasons
check your mic
okay
yeah
so um
fragmentation can happen for many
reasons uh
one reason something can explode like a
fuel tank can get weakened if it's not
empty and it's still pressurized and
it's in orbit for a long time in and out
of the sun
it can just crack and fragment and
explode batteries can explode
um
[Music]
unexplained fragmentations could be
collisions with objects that are too
small to be tracked
and unexplained fragmentations could
even be
anti-satellite weapons
possibly
so
what i did was i took this original
figure from this original paper by
kessler from 78
and i looked in all these reports from
the johnson space center
talking at the different events
that have happened collision events
fragmentation events and i overlaid the
cumulative number
of events
on kessler's graphs
so in the solid orange circles are the
collisions and each time there's a
collision that
it goes up
one more count
and these hollow
orange circles are the collisions plus
the unexplained fragmentation events so
what we see rather interestingly and the
the
uh
the upper right
hollow orange circle is literally off
the chart um i mean it's a little bit
off the chart and uh what we see is that
it's tracking his predictions rather
well
so i thought that was pretty interesting
i should have maybe published this but
this is as far as i got
um
and as i said
as i said uh jfc um
you know here we just in 2020 they
cataloged
five breakup events um i don't know if
they classify them as collisions or just
breakups fragmentations i think these
might have been all fragmentations
and um
you can see some of these things that
say satellite name are actually
satellites and some of them are are
third stages or tanks or cars and
various
large pieces of junk that are up there
now i should point out that the
the
rules have gotten a lot more
draconian
both u.s rules and the and the
u.n rules and like it used to be that
you know
you could like
have a lens cap go flying off of your
telescope and nobody cared and you could
have you know
explosive bolts and fragments everywhere
when you were separating the rocket
stage
and now all that stuff is uh
not allowed at all and all but the most
pariah nation um
uh abide by these conventions
here's a sort of
relatively i think this is from the most
recent issue of the debris journal this
is sort of totals
of the
objects
um
debris the number of spacecraft the
number of debris objects in the total
objects by country
you can see that um
russia and china lead
in debris objects
3800 and 5700 objects respectively
i know i guess the us is up there too
5100 objects um
uh
anyway you might expect the big
spacefaring nation to have most of them
um
and uh when we say total objects in the
lower eye 23 522 that's the number of
objects that are tracked
by the u.s space surveillance network
which is approximately equal to the
number that are
cataloged if you combine all the world's
networks because the us's you might
suspect has been running
and extending their network longest but
the whole question of the world space
surveillance network versus the us space
surveillance network is that it's
another entire discussion but it's it's
a very interesting topic
all these radars all over the place and
telescopes all over the place and how
the data is brought together and who
owns the data and how you
harmonize the data and how different
countries want to spin the data
anyway um
here's a graph that shows
this again for jsc
it shows the
it shows the total number of objects in
space over uh
over the course of the space age
or since the dawn of the space age and
uh they're classified by by different
types as you can see the most important
one is the total objects because when
you're thinking about collisions that's
kind of what matters
um and you'll see that there's those
step functions in there like the thing
labeled
one
two and three
and uh
one of those is the iridium cosmos
collision i mentioned that number one
the thing that kind of drew me and a
bunch of other people in this field
and uh it was not the first collision
we don't think but it was the first one
that produced a lot of debris and uh two
and three were anti-satellite tests
respectively
chinese and russian
and as you may know the us recently
announced a unilateral
ban on anti-satellite weapons testing
some more cynical people might argue
that we did enough of it in the 1970s
and you know don't need to do any more
but um
hopefully the rest of the world will
follow suit because it's one of the most
important things we could do both for
world
stability and you know
also for the
keeping
the orbital environment
safer in terms of debris
uh remember i said there's this we can
track down to about five centimeters but
we have done experiments where we point
high-powered radars they're called beam
park experiments because you park the
radar beam and you just point it at one
spot and as
stuff
go
goes
in orbit you get these radar reflections
so by taking a narrow really high power
pencil radar beam
and one and seeing what comes back you
can
uh get range and cross-section
and get statistics on what's up there
you can't survey the whole sky this way
but you can kind of get the fluxes and
make assumptions that they're uniform
perhaps
and what we see here
is a loglog plot but basically what this
is this is showing you
these
are different
experiments at different times
and
you can see that the number of objects
of smaller size which is the ones on the
left there's exponentially higher
i mean if you go ten times smaller
objects there's like
roughly ten times as many objects so
it's a simple power law and um
and there are
a
thousand times as much flux of
millimeter-sized objects as there is
of say
you know
larger objects this is just saying that
there's a lot of small stuff up there
that we're not tracking and that small
stuff as we saw from the beginning could
be kind of dangerous
um interestingly enough these are not
distributed equally in
space there are certain orbital
altitudes that are much more congested
you can see up
about 850 kilometers
um
there's a lot of congestion
uh
starlink
is getting more congested now this graph
is a little bit obsolete
at these lower altitudes
though it's kind of lucky one nice thing
about really low altitudes like down
below 500 is that stuff just doesn't
stay up very long
atmospheric drag slows it down and as it
slows it down the orbit gets even lower
and then the atmospheric drag get even
higher kind of gets exponentially higher
as you go lower and pretty soon when
you're down at um
you know 400 kilometers you don't have
long to live no matter
unless you're very dense and heavy like
if we took that tungsten ball you know
it might live a long time but but most
satellites or debris is going to live a
very short time
at that altitude
so what do we what can we do to
reduce this problem and ensure that we
can continue going into space and don't
face like a debris minefield that's
impossible
full of satellites and
nuts and bolts other junk well
stop producing debris that's the first
thing so i talked about the rules
there's a lot of detailed rules you have
to get all this stuff approved if you're
going to launch a spacecraft at least in
most countries
uh
you have to show that you have a debris
uh remediation i mean you have to you
have to go through a whole bunch of
things to show that you're not going to
be producing debris that stuff's going
to kind of fall off your spacecraft that
stuff's not going to explode
um
let's stop doing anti-satellite weapons
tests because in a sense they're like
designed to produce debris and um
it's probably not a good idea
um
another thing we can do is you know we
can just slow down launching stuff and
wait and wait for the atmosphere to
clean stuff out and as i said works at
lower altitudes but unfortunately at the
higher altitudes you know a thousand
kilometers and above that stuff's going
to be up there for hundreds or even
thousands of years and when you get up
into like geo
and the higher orbits
they're going to be there
basically forever from our point of view
even from the long now's point of view
you know like millions of years right
um
so
i think this was
i'm going to see if this is a video i
can't remember
it is a video so this is showing this
atmospheric oh that went very fast
all right i guess we're going to skip
that there's this atmospheric cleaning
effect that video is supposed to show
these things still getting caught and
dragged down it's kind of a technical
thing we don't need to do it um the
another thing that helps us
is uh
the solar cycle so the solar the sun has
like seven year cycle or ten years still
depending on how you want to look at it
and it gets active and it gets inactive
and it gets active and it gets inactive
and when it gets active
it it puts out a lot more um
radiation at certain wavelengths and
they don't matter so much to us
down here
hard to detect on the surface of the
earth but in the very upper atmosphere
uh solar activity particularly solar
flares and stuff like that which
happened in this sort of
cycle of seven or 14 years
corresponding with sun spots and all
that stuff
those solar
excursions
make big changes in the extreme upper
atmospheric density they can change the
temperature of the upper atmosphere and
hence the density they like they puff up
the atmosphere of the earth i mean you
wouldn't think of this as atmosphere
it's like pretty much a vacuum but
there's a small amount of gas up there
and it gets way denser
at
two three or
five hundred kilometers even
above the surface of the earth when the
sun gets active and that makes stuff get
dragged down much faster because there's
more atmospheric density it gets slowed
down and then it slows down more and
then it gets denser
the lower atmosphere when it burns up
and so there's this periodic cycle where
if you actually look at um missions
if you look at the checked debris you
can see that there's this kind of
more and less and more and less more and
less that's because every seven years
more of it's getting dragged down oh
that's right there
there you go this is it this is the
solar cycle and the debris reentry is
kind of super posed with each other so
when the sun is active the red curve
more debris re-enters so that's you know
there's some cleaning that's going on
naturally but but not enough
um and this is kind of showing
that that uh cosmos satellite that i was
talking about at the beginning of the
collision
um
this this just shows that uh
for different size objects you know
they're all decaying over time but um
the larger ones take longer
that's interesting the smaller ones
it's kind of just like sand blows in the
wind more easily than big rocks
so
another thing we
do
is we restrict the lifetime of satellite
and meaning so we don't want a bunch of
dead satellites up there there are
already too many and we really don't
want dead satellites up there so what
does that mean
well you can never ensure the satellite
won't die and just remain in orbit as a
basically a big piece of junk but what
you can do is you can
say
you have to dispose of it after a
certain number of years if it's still a
loss so you have to have an engine on it
with enough propellant
to take it
and re-enter into the earth's atmosphere
or at the very least put it into an
orbit that nobody cares about
so those are disposal options another
thing you can do is just fly it very low
to begin with and then you know it's
going to have a very short lifetime
even if it dies
that's what we do at planet labs mostly
is we
build
satellites we launch them into
relatively low orbits
they're only designed to last
say five years
because after five years the technology
is
presumably much better and we don't
really want them anymore so we just have
them
at a lower orbit that after about five
years they re-enter and burn up but
that's not always been the case if
you're building a billion dollar
satellite you might want it to last a
lot longer than five years and therefore
you you have to be very careful and have
some way to dispose of it and
unfortunately
we'll get into this the world's largest
piece of space junk right now is a
billion dollar satellite called nvsat
that the european space european space
agency sent up there it's about the size
of a school bus and it died
and it's totally dead i mean it's and it
just
it's there
these very large
dead objects are in a sense the biggest
threat because if something collides
with them
they can make a huge mess
uh
so
wait
yeah so
they this is related to
there's a lot of proposals also for
going up and getting stuff out of it
that's called active debris removal
and we'll talk a little bit about debris
removal and then and then we'll kind of
summarize and then bring
to an end so um
yeah active to be removed will be the
next topic um
and then after active debris remove
we're going to talk about space traffic
management and collision avoidance which
are two aspects of the same thing you
know given that there's a lot of stuff
up there and given that some of it is
maneuverable and some of it is not
um what can you do to avoid collisions
so
um
the first thing that you can avoid you
do to sort of avoid collisions at least
for active satellites is have a traffic
management system okay like we do with
air traffic management
and you want
you want the satellites to you want
everybody to know where all the
satellites are and you want everything
in an orderly pattern
so that
collisions are very unlikely kind of
like the way we have you know streets
with traffic signals and stuff like that
but satellites
have a different set of
geometries and so
this would be a typical
distribution of satellites in a big
constellation like maybe starlink or
oneweb or something like that i mean
this is simplified but a lot of
satellites in a lot of different orbits
and it might look like a giant mess and
how could you
ever
how could you hope to not have a
collision with a constellation this
dense
but the issue is that if you look at it
in the three-dimensional geometry you
can see that there's ways to kind of
thread stuff through each other
um you can imagine
this thing sort of fully populated with
these orange dots like there could be
thousands and thousands of them up there
and if they're all choreographed just
right they can sort of do a dance i wish
i had a video of this but i will show
some videos kind of like this of what it
would like and one way to understand the
dance is to map it out in in other
coordinate systems so that you know like
latitude and longitude on the earth you
can kind of map it out in these grids
and tauruses where you're using
different mathematical functions and
then they turn into these regular square
patterns and in a sense every satellite
is just sitting in a box now when you
put it back onto the three dimensions of
the sphere of the earth
it doesn't look like a box so much
anymore so here's here's the starlink
constellation and this is we're mapping
it out not in latitude and longitude or
not in altitude and inclination or any
of the standard orbital elements we're
looking at um
[Music]
two kind of derived orbital elements we
don't get into the technologies of it
but they're just simple functions of the
geometry and what we see here is a bunch
of starlink satellites and the ones that
in their assigned orbits are these pale
gray dots and then this
brightly colored ones are the ones that
have been recently launched this was
quite from quite some time ago and now
we're going to watch the evolution as
they continue to launch them and
continue to maneuver them into their
positions
and um
there's a little music there it doesn't
matter so the ones that have recently
been launched are the ones that are
moving and once they get into their
assigned positions they turn they turn
gray
each different launch is a different
color
and you can see as they gray they just
drop on this groove
and this this means that even though
they're all at orbit around the earth in
this complicated dance in their in this
special coordinate system they're just
lying on a grid
the diamond shaped ones are funked some
of those functions
they're really defunct like they have no
control over them anymore
um but the point is that you can see
these gray ones on the right slowing
down and now they're locked into their
position and now we're going to watch
these blue
ones they slow down and they lock into
their position and turn gray and see the
fully building up this grid and and then
when you have this grid if everybody
stays in their box
once it's just a rigid grid and they're
all up there and everybody stays in
their little box there's not going to be
any collisions in that constellation and
so we could have boxes like that uh
globally you know for the entire world
satellites actually and we can have lots
of satellites up there if everybody
stays in their box
and um of course this is complicated by
the fact that you've got debris objects
streaming through here who don't know
about the boxes right
but
it's a story
so what do we do about these debris
objects so we can do active debris
removal
and um
you know everybody's got their favorite
idea or we're going to build with the
robot with claws and it's going to grab
stuff and then bring it back to earth or
we're not like this is an actual uh
an actual
satellite servicing mission but
satellite servicing and debris removal
are very similar you have to get into
proximity of another satellite you have
to
grab grab it you have to attach to it
and then you have to do something either
refuel it or bring it
or
bring it back to atmosphere so it can
burn up or move it to some graveyard
orbit now
um
this is the mission that actually took
place uh
a number of years ago satellite
servicing mission
it was a tech demo it didn't actually
suppress the satellite it kind of
released the thing and then went up to
it and poked around that a little bit
and then grabbed a hold of it again
um but this is very similar to what
you'd have to do
if you were trying to bring a dead
satellite
uh
back
now
the problem is oftentimes debris objects
and objects they're tumbling
makes it harder to
get a hold of them so
of course people have said oh well we'll
just inflate like giant balloons and you
know like we'll like
somehow stick to a balloon or may or
everyone thinks they're very clever why
don't you just send up a net
you know and um
and the thing to remember about this is
these are objects in orbit and if you do
this if you get something wrong you end
up just creating more debris like you
can imagine this net gets tangled up and
then you know now you've got an even
worse problem right and now you've got
an even bigger thing flying around there
or something accidentally
it gets tangled up and it hits someone
else's movies and also by the way all
these kind of schemes like this they
also are like anti-satellite weapons in
disguise because i could just as well
use this to go take your satellite and
and and remove it or to cover it up or
turn it off as i could to get out of
take a piece of space junk out of orbit
uh you know if there's something
something is tumbling you have to you
have to
i don't know where people come up with
these ideas but
i just collected as many as i could
uh you know we're going to catch it with
harpoons
um and then dragged away
now this is actually this is a this was
a european space mission got per far
along planning phase called e.d orbit
this thing on the right is that school
bus sized
gigantic nvsat dead
environmental satellite and then the
thing on the left was going it was fully
all designed and ready to go well it
wasn't built yet it was going to grab
the envy set which was not tumbling i
don't believe
and attach itself to the envy set and
then just de-boost the whole thing down
into the atmosphere and that got
canceled unfortunately so that's envy
set is still up there
um
they are actually this is going to
launch in 2025 this is called clear
space
and um it is
it is going to grab a spent is it a
freak out upper stage
oh someone will have to share the joke
with me
anyway yeah well
uh right anyway it's it's the thing on
the left is is getting this
medium-sized piece of junk that's known
to be up there and um
uh
you're spending 86 million euros on this
mission to bring back this one piece of
junk
uh
so here
so you can imagine a scenario
where you remove the n largest pieces of
junk from orbit every year
and so the question is if you since the
largest pieces of junk are in a sense
the biggest threat because they'll
produce the most additional junk if they
get impacted you might say well what
would this have what effect would this
have overall growth of the debris
population if we removed the n largest
pieces from orbit so since we have good
information about much of what's up
there and um
[Music]
and a lot of historical data here we can
see
various growth scenarios for space
debris this is assuming no additional
anti-satellite weapons tests okay but
this says
um
if you just do business as usual you get
the thick black line
that's going on to the right highest one
and that's just using like the debris
remediation techniques and then if you
use um
if you really if you
add in adro2 which is act debris removal
of the two largest objects the two most
dangerous objects per year
then you obviously the dotted line which
is far less growth and if you go to adr5
that's the line that's almost flat
going into the future and that's if you
remove five
worst offenders every year
so and then those the waviness of those
lines is that solar cycle that i was
talking about so more stuff is going up
there all the time but more stuff being
cleaned out all the time and you can
balance it out
and then if you do a little active
debris removal of just five objects per
year you can flatten this out
so that's kind of that's pretty good
news
um
and uh okay now we're gonna get a little
bit so
there's a japanese anime series
which is all about space junk collectors
the space garbage men and this is what
they do i understand it's very popular
i've only watched one episode i think
it's mostly about the relationships and
the drama but they happen to be um
space garbage collectors i mean and
again
and then there's okay then everyone's
like why go up there with
hooks and snares and
nets and balloons why not to send a
giant laser up there and blast it and
vaporize it
it's like yes that was called star wars
that was like that's called space
weapons and that is arguably
i mean if you have megawatt class lasers
in space
oh they're just up there to sell you
know mitigate debris
this is going to be a hard sell it's
also it's very hard to make a megawatt
laser even on the earth no one's come
close i think to a megawatt continuous
wave laser and um
and making it in space probably too
expensive and too dangerous ming the
merciless was the only one who was
capable of building such lasers as i
understand it
ahead of his time exactly um
and uh that's the thing these things are
also
weapons
uh
so it but it turns out you can build
and in fact sandra may even actually
have owned at one point if a
multi-kilowatt class continuous wave
laser you can you can get now 10
kilowatt class
continuous wave lasers for machine shops
they're these are the upper end of the
uh industrial lasers but they're
they're uh
they're they're commonplace now and so
some cogs and i ask him with a thing we
called light force
uh which was a way to use relatively low
power lasers
to do space collision avoidance not
blast things out of the sky or vaporize
them
but um
this is work that will marshall and i
did um back at nasa and as well as a
number of others whose names i shall
mention later and the idea was to use a
ground-based laser hooked up to a
moderate sized telescope shown here in
the center
and
you're let's say you're tracking a piece
of debris
that can't maneuver on its own
and you
have a prediction that it's going to
collide with another piece of debris
that can't maneuver on its own now these
are the kind of in a way the worst
problems because first of all there's
arguably more debris than there is
uh non-debris up there and the second is
that debris in general you know debris
can't maneuver so there's no chance of
somebody moving out of the way under
their own power so the question is how
do you prevent debris debris collision
debris debris collisions
and the idea is if you shine this laser
through this telescope on a piece of
debris
you're not gonna vaporize it or anything
like that you're going to put a little
bit of what's called radiation pressure
on it the kind of thing that spins those
little solar spinny things in those
evacuated bulbs
radiation pressure is the thing it
actually you have to take the sun's
radiation pressure into account when
you're calculating the trajectory of a
satellite in orbit it's a slight
perturbing force in addition to gravity
and atmospheric drag so radiation
pressure is a thing and it turns out
that by using one of these industrial 10
kilowatt class lasers and a telescope
of moderate
aperture like a university class
telescope like a one meter aperture
telescope
using a laser in that telescope and some
additional hardware you can put enough
light energy on a piece of debris that
is equivalent to about what it would see
in the sun but you can
put it either to slow it down in its
orbit or to speed it up in its orbit if
you point it right direction at the
right time and you can perturb the
trajectory of that object that's what's
shown here
on the upper right of this diagram is
like
the unperturbed trajectory without the
laser engagement and the perturbed
trajectory with the laser engagement you
only impart
a few millimeters per second of delta v
with each of these engagements but it
turns out a few millimeters per second
over the course of a few hours or days
amounts to
a lot of distance that you can perturb
the end
position of this object and so you can
actually uh avoid collisions this way
the question is you know how
how how well does this actually work
what are the numbers actually say how
much is it going to cost
so we made the proposal
um
a whole bunch of organizations teamed up
uh
really great great team and we made a
proposal
and proposed it and um
to nasa
when they were calling for proposals for
uh debris remediation and and that sort
of thing
here's the picture of
one of these lasers it's about i don't
know how much these things cost a
fraction of a million dollars i think
maybe less
that's about the size of a large fridge
um here's a one meter class telescope
that's also about
a million bucks maybe a little less
and
here's the high power adaptive optics
system that's another thing you need for
this and then if you combine this stuff
together
this is showing like one piece of debris
it'll make passes over this laser and
sometimes you'll be able to engage it
for a short time and sometimes you'll be
able to engage it for a long time and
maybe
since it's orbiting the earth like
roughly every 90 minutes most definitely
a little earth orbit is orbiting every
90 minutes you would engage for maybe
uh 16 illuminations over the course of
24 hours some of the longer some of them
are shorter and you could end up
returning the position of this object by
engaging with the laser and just giving
it a gentle little pushes uh you could
perturb enough that
uh
down the line you've altered it's it's
trajectory by hundreds or even thousands
of meters that's shown here the
perturbed versus unperturbed trajectory
this is with actual physics in the model
okay
and um
yeah so you could build one of these
stations for maybe let's say 10 million
and then it'd have to be automated and
you'd have to maybe we figured you'd
want to have like maybe damn on the
walls
near the poles you know where there's a
lot of
overhead passes of most debris objects
because they're in orbits that take them
near the poles most of the time so for
like 100 million dollars you could build
this thing which could which could
probably
uh
drastically reduce the possibility of
collisions for like 90 percent of the
debris debris collisions in orbit so for
100 million so maybe maybe even a little
more than that just this was not
expensive enough for nasa frankly
and um
and they did something i hate to be so
cynical it's like somewhere just don't
want to hear that you can solve a
problem
for you know less than
a billion dollars and
anyway
it turns out the australian colleagues
then actually went and kind of did this
they just demoed it they had the laser
they had the telescope
and they
they did some demo of this
so there was i'm going to skip this
lightsaber yeah so this was we did
experiments at the starfire
optical range
the air force did some experiments with
us they loved this idea they love they
have the big laser they shoot into space
for reasons they won't talk about and
they're loving the idea that there was
sort of an environmental beneficial
reason to shoot these lasers into space
uh system diagram of the of the thing we
were proposing with the australians
here they are actually prototyping it on
their optical image this is the high
power adaptive optics thing but that's
the technicality but because of the
atmosphere you have to have some fancy
corrective optics
and uh
there's the australian facility
mount dromlo wonderful people
and they uh
well that's not very visible that's
that's a that is a picture from the
internet panel when they were engaging a
debris object with a laser
so this works
i'm going to last last thing i'm going
to talk about is um
a debris
by george darver from nasa ames this is
brilliant he came up with this thing
again it's probably not expensive enough
but i mean it really makes sense okay
and this is like let's say you have like
one of those swarms like you saw in the
movie the gravity movie or like there's
like
a thousand nuts and bolts and little
things all coming
you know because maybe something
maybe something fragmented and it's like
a it's sort of a jet
anyway it's like how could you possibly
remove debris like that like you're not
gonna
you know do that with harpoons right so
his scheme is you launch a rocket which
is basically carrying a payload that
just a big tank of of liquid carbon
dioxide and i don't know if you ever
played with liquid carbon dioxide in a
tank but what happens when you crack the
tank
and when you launch this thing into a
retrograde orbit meaning the opposite
orbit if you have this cloud of
different particles coming you lost this
tank of co2 so that it's going to
intersect the cloud
and
you make it time it so it's going to
intersect it
on the night side of the earth and then
right
just in time
the co2 tank vents all of its co2
which goes from liquid phase
quickly to gas and then it turns into
crystals dry ice crystals it's on the
night side of the earth so these dry ice
crystals just sit there imagine like
this long contrail of dry ice crystals
that's been precision laid out so that
the debris cloud is going to pass right
through it
and then the debris cloud and then the
the rocket kind of re-enters itself
using its own jets of co2 leaves this
three cloud contrail right in the path
of the oncoming debris and the oncoming
debris comes and it just gets ablated by
this cloud of dry crystals
all the nuts and bolts and everything
slowed down
burned up
and then what happens
20 minutes later the earth rotates and
all this is in the day side and the
crystals just sublime
and
instantly dissipate
because they turn
into gas which
expands immediately
so i thought that's a brilliant scheme
maybe we'll do that someday
real practical ones
um so we've kind of gone through a bunch
of this stuff this is i'm going to end
here i've been just going to mention in
yellow here there's like all kinds of
other stuff to talk about
the whole technical regulatory
international this is a one of these
problems that has so many moving parts
you know socially politically
economically it's a coordination problem
um
yeah i think i'm going to end it
there thanks very much
[Applause]
i think we're down to one mic is that
correct oh two mics
we have two mics which also means that i
don't think we can pass one around we'll
just take questions and i'll repeat them
as we have them um so thank you i wanna
i really appreciate that you actually
showed a hopeful view of space debris in
this talk which is very rare that we get
to see but i also want to like take a
step back to the kessler syndrome itself
so he predicted
that um
that we were going to have this
increasing curve of of material
um but
there was a syndrome that he talked
about specifically about what was going
to happen
in that case that might change the way
that humans interact with space can you
just outline that a little bit further
well the idea the idea is that if there
if if debris collisions produce more
debris and produce more debris at a
higher rate than it can be naturally
removed or
removed by humans then
you end up with just a
an impassable cloud
around the earth and you can just not be
able to launch anything into space maybe
for
thousands of years even it would be like
so ironic if starlink made it like if
the guy who wants to make us a
multi-planetary species and causing the
kessler syndrome with
this satellite constellation
that would truly be ironic and and
tragic but um uh i
yeah so the syndrome is the idea that
there's this runaway chain reaction and
and it just becomes
i don't want to say uninhabitable but
but sort of on space becomes unusable at
least in near
so expensive to
start removing things that it's kind of
impossible for a long time yeah or we'd
have to have some new thinking
right and i also that i remember when
you first
were working with planet and you were
telling me about the you know this
the expanding and contracting notion of
um the earth's atmosphere that actually
is a self-cleaning notion was something
that totally was new to me
um and is there a way that uh companies
like planet and or some in starlink are
they being required to do anything that
puts you know
forces them to put drag or forces them
to be have de-orbiting capability oh
absolutely yeah there's new regs all the
time now we're not going to be able to
launch satellites without propulsion
soon and the main reason for the
propulsion from the point of view of the
regulatory agencies is collision
avoidance and
end-of-life
disposal you know whether you want to
use the propulsion for other purposes
you know that's kind of up to you but
yeah uh
there's a lot of
new regulations
tracking
propulsion
um
stuff like that and when i visited you
guys in south america there's like a
couple of your uh
places your offices ago but it was kind
of stunning to me after going to a nasa
launch and then showing up at planet
there was you know you were tracking
at that time hundreds of
satellites from
one screen in itself the market um and
then going to you know nasa where
they're like hundreds of people tracking
one thing
um but that kind of difference that's
happening in the um now that we have
uh
so many private efforts how do they
you mentioned this coordination thing
how how is the coordination happening
both between international
secret things of military and
secret things in the private world
um
yeah that was a lot of stuff in there um
so let's let's talk about first is there
one database how does how does it work
uh there's
there's essentially one database
no even that's complicated everybody
knows it's kind of like asking is there
one um
search engine you know what i mean like
there's several of them and most
professionals know how to use multiple
ones and that's not a huge issue um
and there's ways to combine them to get
higher accuracy
fune and all that stuff i want to give
some credit to nasa and these places
look one i love planet labs but when we
have hundreds of when we have hundreds
of satellites controlled by one person
these are like basically simple little
webcams in space with some radios on
board when nasa has hundreds of people
controlling something it's like the
space station or a mars rover or
something like this it's like a whole
other level of complexity and risk
i mean one of our one of our satellite
goes out is no huge deal if
if one of those mars rovers goes out
it's like hundreds of careers and and
and you know billions of dollars so
there's a reason that they
we do things differently
uh
i have the highest respect for nasa in
many ways in spite of my snarky comments
earlier um okay
and then what was this about
coordination like who's involved yeah i
mean so i mean i assume there's many
secret objects in space there's no no
there's not many semi-secret objects
that people don't want to talk about but
then if there's going to be a collision
with a like a
a defense agency thing
versus a look
let me say that let me say something who
gets the call
uh they both get the call everybody
who's involved in a potential collision
gets a call everyone who's involved in a
conjunction that they say
gets a call i mean if unless it's like a
piece of debris of unknown origin that's
like who could possibly get the call in
that case but
uh
i want to mention just one other thing
that relates to this question
the secret objects is not such a big
deal
um
but but the weird part is that some of
the main
technical and organizational
infrastructure that is responsible for
doing the tracking is
they kind of have
this is now the space force it used to
be called the joint space operation
center they have
it's not part of the space force it's
not the entire space force they have
these two conflicting
goals on the one hand we are supposed to
assure u.s space superiority
in the military and on the other hand
they're supposed to ensure safe
careful stewardship
of the orbital environment and the
latter would
presumably
be something
increased transparency
be in service of but to ensure u.s space
superiority maybe increased transparency
isn't the way to go and the same agency
has both missions and so there's going
to be some internal conflict there and
that's just one of the problems you know
uh just thought i'd mention that and i
assume other countries have their own
parallel efforts that they share or do
not share
they have efforts that they share and
efforts that they do not share indeed
[Laughter]
thank you for that
and one of the things that i don't think
we talked about you kind of showed it at
the beginning but like what are the what
are the velocities that we are talking
about like average average average low
earth orbit collision velocity is uh
many kilometers per second uh
miles per hour
uh
tens of thousands of miles i mean it's
like 10 times faster than a rifle bullet
in general so hyper velocity sonic
and you mentioned one of those
unpredicted uh collisions that happened
with the
canada arm
and a few of those like how many of
those are we now seeing per year
well
again to see it we have to either have
astronauts up there noticing that
there's a hole or there was one before
or we have to see some event with the
radar on earth and that means it's got
to have big
big fragments so we're only seeing right
now
as i said at fragmentations like
from zero to
three or four a year maybe five in the
but
we don't really know this micro
fragmentations could be happening more
frequently
and we have a question from the
internets and we're gonna grab some
questions here from the audience next as
well
um
is there is there a current curve that's
heading us towards a kessler syndrome
that
if you if if left alone where would we
where would we be
uh if left alone like every step i mean
you showed a curve that was going up
that we were hoping to flatten right of
space debris at what point does that
curve
oh well don't forget that curve
when i plotted those points on top of
kessler's thing i mean we were talking
about over the course of many decades an
aggregate of like 12 clones so we're not
in like any sort of
a horrible situation right now um
you'd have to extrapolate those curves
much farther to have a real
impenetrable
wall of space to bring in orbit around
the earth uh the curves that showed
those growth scenarios that were
actually coming from the nasa three-off
show a more linear
growth
scenario
um
that's
that's i think more like what's in our
near future and the question is are we
just going to let it get worse and worse
or are we going to flatten it out it's
not that much work to flatten it out uh
is it going to go non-linear it depends
on your kind of depends on your time
scale like almost almost any curve is
linear
if you zoom in far enough
all right do we have any questions uh
short uh questions
charles
let me repeat that just since we don't
have a mic out there so
given what's up there right now what is
the chances of a
big nasty collision we've already had
two that were maybe planned or were like
the chinese one in the russian one but
something on the order of the gravity
kind of
collision this is very hard because this
is
kind of one of these
low probability high impact
events
uh
it's like a poisson process so you know
it
it's like
if
i don't know how to answer that the
gravity thing was
exaggerated and it wouldn't really go
like that but like what's the
probability of a big object smashing
into the space station that's very low
because we know where the big objects
are and we know where the space station
is and we're going to move the space
station out of the way
okay
but um
but
that iridium cosmos collision that kind
of drugged me into this which produced
thousands of fragments
many of which are re-entered by now but
um
yeah i think we can expect to see
every few years
something like that may be bigger it's
on process so sometimes
a lot of them come and then there's a
big gap
fair enough other questions
paul
first thing came to
somebody possibly mind
that as a way to create an asap
uh put a satellite orbit in other words
debris
into
the trajectory to hit something and if
so could it be detected that was if i
were a small
hold on let me just recap this yeah so
the question is could you use
any of these systems like the what the
laser system you mentioned um
effectively to push something into
a correlated orbit um and if it did
happen would anybody be able to detect
that it was happening
i think the answer is it would be very
hard and you could detect it and it
doesn't really matter because how would
you even know if some of nudgy's debris
or if it was just
that was how it was headed i mean what
i'm saying is that you'd see that
there's a collision probability and it's
getting worse as time goes on and so
you'd make a maneuver and
if you're just trying to make debris
collide with other debris that's just
terrorism that's that like you're not
taking out anyone's asset there you're
just making a mess
any questions
in the back there
yes
yeah are the graphs including the
particles that are too small to be
tracked is that what you're asking
so they could have probabilities but
we're not tracking them is that what
you're asking yeah
some of the graphs showed
particles
that are
smaller
than the ones that are tracked because
we do know something about what's up
there of even a very small size like
like that's the reason they brought back
those panels from the hubble space
telescope it's like well those things
have been there for nine years and you
know they're gonna have nine years worth
of bombardment and then you can go look
and see how many holes of given size
there are and you can at least know
roughly the statistics of what's up
there and how dangerous it is obviously
you're not tracking every single
sand grain or bb in orbit not yet it
could make ourselves
but um
so it's kind of a mixed bag we know
something about
the statistics and distributions of the
smaller objects and something about how
dangerous they are but we certainly
don't know where everyone is at all
times
all right so i'm going to wrap this up
and people we're going to stay here and
people can ask more questions but i want
to kind of bring this back to that
original kind of question of threat
models that we all have to hold in our
heads
these days
um is this question of you know where
does this fit in your head in the world
of something like climate change or an
asteroid impact or some other kind of
existential threat like how do you put
this into your
yeah well okay
i'll end on a
controversial no climate change is not
an existential threat
it's not an existential to the threat to
the planet or even to humans it it could
be a serious
problem that could set our civilization
back
maybe
irrevocably back even i mean so could
the kessler syndrome could lock us here
on earth there are similarities i mean
and and neither is it syndrome an
existential threat like the worst gonna
do is you know keep us from going into
space for a thousand years okay we would
last a long time without ever going into
space okay um
but i'd like to
an astropex i don't
that's too far
that's too different i think
there's great similarities and great
differences between the space debris
problem and the climate problem and i'd
like to focus
uh they both seem similar because
they're like global environmental
problems and it's a coordination problem
because you have to try and get
everybody to do something and it's going
to be very it's going to be somewhat
expensive
in the case of space debris and
horrifically expensive in the case of
carbon emissions at least that part of
climate change to
mitigate in the standard stupid ways
that they want to mitigate it
i should be careful what i say but uh
but
there are similar problems in this way
they are from the sky
they're like
involving the whole earth
but they're also very different problems
climate change and
space debris i mean space debris is a
simple problem first of all there's no
question about are humans contributing
to it or not like okay
um
secondly and how much are they
problem right exactly there's no
it's all anthropogenic space theory
pretty much and uh then there's um
and then there's the uh the issue of
like how good are the models well like
people argue about these climate models
all the time it's it's like
so hard i would i'd venture it's almost
impossible it's not my field but it's
like i've done flu mexican chemistry and
i can tell you we can't even do
tiny little
airplanes and simple molecules very good
the idea we're going to model the whole
planet with the sun and the
magnetosphere and the biosphere and the
oceans and make predictions down to a
fraction of degrees celsius over the
course of decades i find that
preposterous and
and contrast that with space debris it's
like newtonian orbits and collision
statistics there's really no
not much to argue about right
it's like the models are pretty simple
you can run them on a laptop
well i like coming out of here thinking
that space debate is less of a problem
that i want going in so thank you for
that
thank you all for coming uh and i have a
i have a gift for you here somewhere
a challenge coin which i know you
probably already have yeah but i lost my
challenge coin which is like such a
loser thing to do so it's perfect
excellent thank you so much and if you
guys could grab your glasses leave your
chairs our staff will and then just get
out of the way we'll move chairs out of
the way but if you grab your glasses so
they don't all break that would be
awesome thank you
[Music]
you